Casey obviously you're in the middle of
a press tour during a hard time in your
family's life so I just want to ask you
you know how's Ben what's it like for
you to watch him work on himself and
what do you hope he sort of learns from
doing this and be in the public eye
during it I'm not sure what there is to
say my you know we come from my father
is an alcoholic as bad as you can be and
he's been sober for about thirty years
I've been sober for about six years and
Ben is trying to put it together and
it's it can be a very hard thing to do
and he has the kind of resources in time
luckily to take the time and to go to a
good facility and you know it has a
alcoholism has a huge impact on not just
the person but also their family and so
I think for his kids sake and for their
mom I think he's and for himself he's
trying to do the work and go together do
you think it's harder to do it in
Hollywood your own experience it's can't
be easier to have everybody looking at
you and taking your picture you know
it's you're like walking out of an
intervention so it's I I don't envy that
and you know I saw my father struggle
with it for many years and nobody was
following him around with cameras and
stuff it's it's nothing it's not a great
look but on the other hand it's nothing
to be ashamed of and it's good that he's
taking care of it he also spoke with
Casey about starring alongside tika
Sumpter and Hollywood greats like Robert
Redford and [ __ ] Spacek in the upcoming
movie the old man and the gun working
with [ __ ] and Robert on this is there a
memory that you'll take for the rest of
your life
well we did a scene in a diner when she
died were sitting at the diner and they
were at another table not looking at us
they're paying attention to us not
really in the scene with us perfect but
that was still very exciting and as
exciting as it is to be in a scene Atika
I think that both of us kept kind of
like sneaking looks over her shoulder
playing there singing over there that
was our first memory and oh great
they're really both just their legends
you've been watching them in movies
forever they've been great forever and
it's you have to kind of forget about
that just be in the room with them and
[Music]